TEST
TEST.
TEST.  .  TEST.  TEST.  TEST.
TEST. . . .
SPEAKER:  HELLO EVERYONE.
WELCOME TO THE YOUNG READERS
CENTER IN THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.  ARE YOU EXCITED?
PLEASE GIVE A WARM APPLAUSE.
BECAUSE WE HAD SOME TROUBLE
GETTING HERE.
WELCOME.  MY NAME IS GALIA
YELLA WITH THE SPANISH DIVISION
IN THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS AND I
AM EXCITED TO PRESENT TO YOU
CHILDREN'S AUTHOR, LULU DELACRE.
[APPLAUSE].  LULU DELACRE WAS
BORN IN PUERTO RICO IN 1957 AND
THE AUTHOR AND ILLUSTRATOR OF
MANY AWARDS AND BOOKS, AND HER
MOST RECENT WORK SHE WILL
PRESENT TODAY.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  "OLINGUITO FROM A TO
Z" PUBLISHED IN 2016 BY LEE AND
LORA BOOKS.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH]:
HOW FAR DO YOU LOVE ME?  THE
STORY TELLERS.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  GENTLE GAMES.  AMONG
OTHERS.  WE WILL DECLARE THE
FIRST FROM OUR TRAINING WHEN SHE
WAS BORN IN ARGENTINA WHERE SHE
WAS ENCOURAGED AND TAUGHT TO BE
MY HER MOTHER AND STUDIED IN
PUERTO RICO TO CONTINUE HER
STUDIES IN FRANCE.  I HAVE TO
TRANSLATE THAT.  BECAUSE I DON'T
SPEAK FRENCH.  THE WINNER OF
HONORS AND [SPEAKING SPANISH].
CONGRESS.  [APPLAUSE].
DIAS.  AH.  [SPEAKING SPANISH].
YOU HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT ME.
BUT WE ARE HERE.  BECAUSE WE ARE
CELEBRATING A VERY, VERY
SPECIAL OCCASION.  WE ARE
CELEBRATING DIA.  DIA DE LOS
NINOS.  THAT IS CHILDREN'S DAY.
BOOK DAY.  WE CELEBRATE THIS
ALL ACROSS AMERICA.  THIS IS THE
DAY THAT WE CELEBRATE BOOKS.
THAT TALK ABOUT ALL CHILDREN,
ALL ETHNICITIES, ALL
BACKGROUNDS, ALL LANGUAGES.
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].
RAISE RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
ARE BILINGUAL.  SO, OY
VAMOS.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  I AM GOING TO TALK
ABOUT HOW IS IT THAT I CREATED
SOME BOOK
"OLINGUITO FROM A TO Z"
UNVEILING THE CLOUD FOR IT.  BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE'RE GOING TO
START FROM THE START.  DO YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE VERY FIRST
THING THAT YOU NEED IN ORDER TO
WRITE A BOOK?  IT'S NOT PEN AND
PAPER.  NO THINGS THAT YOU CAN
TOUCH.  IT IS SOMETHING THAT
COMES FROM HERE.  WHAT IS IT?  I
WANT A HAND.  JUST A HAND.
WHAT IS IT?  WHAT IS IT?  YES?
AN IDEA.  THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED.  BEHIND EVERY SINGLE BOOK
IN THIS AMAZING LIBRARY.
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].  AND THIS IS MY IDEA
BEHIND THIS BOOK.  I WANTED TO
CREATE A BOOK WITH A SPANISH
ALPHABET.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
GO ABOUT IT.  SO ONE DAY, I
OPENED THE NEWSPAPER, THE
WASHINGTON POST BY THE WAY.
[SPEAKING SPANISH].  I FOUND AN
ARTICLE.  AND THIS ARTICLE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AMAZING ANIMAL
CALLED
OLINGUITO.  CAN YOU REPEAT THAT
WITH ME?
OLINGUITO.
FABULOUS.  OLINGUITO.  SO I READ
ABOUT THIS ANIMAL.  AND I SAID
OH, OLINGUITO, I HAVE MY OWN.
BUT THEN I NEEDED TO FIND ALL OF
THE OTHER LETTERS ARE FROM THE
SPANISH ALPHABET.  I NEEDED TO
FIND ALL THE ANIMALS OR AMAZING
ANIMALS AND PLANTS THAT
CO-EXIST WITH OLINGUITO IN THE
CLOUD FOREST OF ECUADOR.  THAT
TOOK ME A LONG TIME.  AND BEFORE
I TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT, AND I
READ YOU THE BOOK, I WANT TO
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
OLINGUITO AND ABOUT THE CLOUD
FOR IT.
THE OLINGUITO IS A SMALL SOFT
ANIMAL AND THEY SAY IT HAS THE
FACE OF A TEDDY BEAR AND THE
TAIL OF A CAT.  IT IS VERY, VERY
SMALL.  ACTUALLY THIS IS THE
EXACT SIZE.  VERY SMALL.  AND IT
LIVES IN THE CLOUD FOREST OF
ECUADOR.  IT'S AN NOCTURNAL
ANIMAL.  DOES ANYBODY KNOW WHAT
NOCTURNAL MEANS?  HANDS.  LET'S
SEE.  LET'S SEE.  OVER THERE.
NOCTURNAL NOCTURNAL, WHAT DOES
THAT
MEAN?
ANIMAL NOCTURNAL.  YES,MEAN?
ANIMAL NOCTURNAL.  YES,
NOCTURNAL MEANS -- [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  A NOCTURNAL ANIMAL,
DOES IT COME AROUND DAY TO DAY.
NOCTURNAL, IT COMES AROUND AT
NIGHT.  IT LIVES IN THE CANOPY
OF THE CLOUD FOREST.  THAT MEANS
IT DOESN'T COME DOWN FROM THE
TREE TOPS.  AND WHY IS IT THAT
IT TOOK SO LONG TO FIND THIS
LITTLE ANIMAL?  WELL, IT TOOK
VERY VERY LONG BECAUSE I HAVE TO
TELL YOU NOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE CLOUD FOREST.  WHY DO YOU
SUPPOSE THE CLOUD FOREST IS
CALLED THE CLOUD FOREST?  WHAT
IS THE USE?  [SPEAKING SPANISH].
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.  THE CLOUD
FOREST IS FILLED WITH CLOUDS.
FOREST.  THEREFORE, THINK.  PUT
ON YOUR THINKING CAPS.  THINKING
CAPS ON.  DO YOU THINK THAT IS
VERY EASY TO SEE AN ANIMAL THIS
SIZE WHEN IT'S ALL VERY, VERY,
VERY DARK, THERE IS NO
LIGHT AT NIGHT.  WE ARE NOT IN
THE CITY WE ARE IN A FOREST.
[SPEAKING SPANISH].  THERE IS A
FOREST WHERE THERE IS NO LIGHT
WHATSOEVER.  DO YOU THINK IT IS
VERY EASY TO SEE AN ANIMAL THAT
COMES ONLY AT NIGHT IN A VERY
DARK FOREST?  AND IF THAT FOREST
IS ALSO COVERED WITH FOG AND
MIST.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].
NO.
NO.  NO.  OKAY.  NO.  YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT ANSWER.  NO.  SO THAT
IS WHY IT TOOK SO
LONG.
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].  I AM GOING TO TELL
YOU HOW IS IT THAT THAT
HAPPENED.  A GROUP OF
SCIENTISTS, NOT FROM HERE.
ACTUALLY A
GROUP OF SCIENTISTS THAT WORKED
IN THE SMITHSONIAN INSTITUTION.
THEY WORKED FOR 10 YEARS
FINDING AND DETERMINING THE
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS OF A
CERTAIN ANIMAL LIKE THE
OLINGUITO CALLED THE OLINGO,
THAT COMES FROM THE SAME FAMILY.
FAMILY OF THE
RACCOON AND ONE DAY THE
SCIENTISTS FOUND OUT,
OUT,ZOOLOGY, THERE WERE SOME
LABELED OLINGUITO THAT WERE
DIFFERENT.  AND SOME BONES, YOU
KNOW, THE FUR THAT WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TOO.  AND THESE
ZOOLOGISTS BEGAN TO SUSPECT THAT
THIS WAS MISLABELED.  AND THIS
TESTAMENT THAT HE HAD BEEN
STUDYING IN THE MUSEUM OF
NATURAL HISTORY HAD BEEN
MISLABELED.  AND HE CONDUCTED
SOME VERY SPECIAL TESTING.  DNA
TESTING.  AND YOU KNOW WHAT HE
FOUND?  DO YOU WANT TO KNOW?
THAT THIS WAS NOT AN OLINGUITO.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT ANIMAL.  SO
THESE SCIENTISTS GATHERED A
GROUP OF OTHER SCIENTISTS, AND
THEY WENT ALL THE WAY DOWN SOUTH
TO THE COUNTRY OF ECUADOR.
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
THEY WANTED TO KNOW IF THE
ANIMAL WAS ALIVE AND WELL IN THE
FOREST.  OKAY.
NOW I'M GOING TO STOP.  AND I AM
GOING TO READ YOU -- WELL
ACTUALLY I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
THIS STORY OF THE OLINGUITO IN
SPANISH.  AND THEN WE WILL SEE
THE STORY DEVELOP, SHOWN ON THE
SCREEN IN ENGLISH.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  AND NOW LET'S GO INTO
THE FOREST.  I WENT TO THE
FOREST.  I WENT TO THE
FOREST IN
ECUADOR.  WHERE OLINGUITO
LIVES.
AND I WENT THERE BECAUSE I
WANTED TO SEE WITH MY OWN EYES,
NOT ONLY THE OLINGUITO, BUT I
WANTED TO
SEE THE AMAZING PLANTS AND
AMAZING ANIMALS THAT CO-EXIST
WITH THE OLINGUITO.  I DIDN'T
TELL YOU SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT.  AND THAT IS, THAT IN
A CLOUD FOREST, NOT ONLY THE
CLOUD FOREST IS KNOWN FOR
THE CLOUDS THAT COVER EVERY
SINGLE PART OF THE FOREST.  WE
HAVE A LOT OF PLANTS.  AND THESE
PLANTS, MANY OF THESE PLANTS
ARE AIR PLANTS.  YOU HAVE THE
CLOUDS AND THE FOG COVERING ALL
OVER THE FOREST.  AND YOU ALSO
HAVE MANY PLANTS THAT ARE AIR
PLANTS.
LIKE THE CAMILIAS LIKE YOU SAW
THERE.  REMEMBER WHEN I STARTED?
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
WHAT YOU SEE UP THERE ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW, THOSE ARE AIR
PLANTS.  THIS PLANT, THIS IS ONE
OF THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
CLOUD FOREST.  THE CLOUD FOREST
IS KNOWN TO HAVE A LOT OF MIST.
A LOT OF HUMIDITY THAT ACTUALLY
ARE NUTRIENTS.  THEY NOURISH
ALL OF THE AIR
PLANTS.  AND ALSO THE LIGHTS,
THEY ARE AIR PLANTS.
AND HERE YOU CAN SEE THE WATER.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SEE UP
THERE?  WHO IS EATING THE
BANANA?  WHO IS EATING THE
BANANA?
SPEAKER:  I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  OLINGUITO.
SPEAKER:  YEAH, OLINGUITO.  YOU
KNOW I WAITED 4 HOURS THAT NIGHT
WAITING FOR OLINGUITO TO
ARRIVE.
AND I WAS STAYING IN THIS LODGE
IN THE CLOUD FOREST.  AND THE
MANAGER HAD PROMISED ME THAT I
WOULD SEE AN OLINGUITO.  AND I
WAS STAYING THERE JUST THREE
NIGHTS.  I HAD JUST THREE NIGHTS
TO SEE IF.  IF I DON'T SEE IT,
I'M GOING TO BE VERY, VERY, VERY
SAD.  SO I WAS STANDING THERE
WITH MY CAMERA AND I HAD SOME
FRIENDS IN THE BEGINNING.  BUT
BY HOUR NUMBER FOUR, I WAS THERE
ALL BY MYSELF.  EVERYBODY HAD
GONE TO BED.  I WAS STILL THERE
WITH MY CAMERA.  I WANTED TO
SNAP A PICTURE OF THE OLINGUITO.
I WAS SO NERVOUS THAT MY HANDS
WERE SHAKING.  I COULDN'T TAKE A
GOOD PICTURE.  THAT'S WHY IT'S
KIND OF FUZZY.  BUT I'LL TELL
YOU WHAT IT IS THAT THE
OLINGUITO IS EATING THE BANANAS.
THE BANANAS DON'T GROW AT THE
ALTITUDE THAT THE OLINGUITOS
LIVE IN THE FOREST.  BANANAS
GROW AT A LOWER ALTITUDE, IN THE
JUNGLE OR THE RAIN FOREST.  SO
THE MANAGER TIES BATCHES OF
BANANAS FROM THE TREE.  REMEMBER
I TOLD YOU THE OLINGUITO DOES
NOT COME DOWN FROM THE CANOPY OF
THE TREES?  REMEMBER I TOLD YOU
-- [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  SO THE MANAGER TIES
BUNCHES OF BANANAS.
AND THIS IS SUCH A SPECIAL TREAT
FOR THE OLINGUITO THAT SURE
ENOUGH, WHEN HE SMELLS THE
BANANA, IT APPROACHES.  AND
THERE IT IS.  THAT IS HOW I GOT
TO TAKE A PICTURE.  SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO READ THE BOOK IN
ENGLISH.  COME, ZOOLOGY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. AS HE SERVES
FOR THE OLINGUITO
ELUSIVE IN THE CLOUD FOREST.
DOES ANYBODY KNOW WHAT THE WORD
ELUSIVE MEANS?  IT'S HARD TO
FIND.
REMEMBER OLINGUITO WAS HARD TO
FIND?  WHY WAS IT HARD TO FIND?
WHY?  YES, THE GIRL IN RED.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IT ONLY COMES
AT NIGHT.
SPEAKER:  DOES ANYBODY ELSE
REMEMBER WHY ELSE IT'S HARD TO
FIND?  IT ONLY COMES AT NIGHT.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE CLOUD FOREST.
WHAT ABOUT THAT IT'S HARD TO SEE
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE CLOUD
FOREST?
WHAT IS IT?  WHAT
IS IT?  YES?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  CLOUDS.
SPEAKER:  EXACTLY.  ABSOLUTELY.
YOU HAVE SO MANY CLOUDS AND FOG
AND MIST, IT'S VERY HARD TO SEE.
SO HIGH UP, BLOOMS THE
FOREST EMBROIDED, HOME TO CRAB
AND SNAIL, HUMMINGBIRDS AND
COTTONTAILS AND A DOZING
OLINGUITO DREAMING THE DAY AWAY,
AND I CAN HEAR SOME OF YOU ARE
VERY EXCITED.  BECAUSE YOU HAVE
ALREADY SPOTTED THE OLINGUITO.
YES.  THE OLINGUITO IS UP ON
THAT TREE. BUT
HE IS SLEEPING.
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].
SO I AM GOING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING ELSE.  THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU DON'T KNOW
YET.  OR MAYBE YOU DO.  BUT IN
EVERY SINGLE STAGE OF THE BOOK,
THERE IS A ZOOLOGIST.  REMEMBER
THE SCIENTIST THAT WENT TO
SEARCH
FOR THE OLINGUITO?  REMEMBER?
SO I HEAR THE ZOOLOGISTS ON
EVERY SINGLE PAGE OF THE BOOK.
OKAY, THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PLAY THE GAME.  OKAY.  LISTEN
TO ME.  I'M GOING TO READ.  I'M
GOING TO READ, AND THEN IF YOU
SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST, THE
SILLIOUETTE OF A MAN, YOU RAISE
YOUR HAND.  YOU RAISE YOUR HAND
WITHOUT SAYING A WORD.  CAN
ANYBODY SEE THE OLINGUITO ON
THIS PAGE?  RAISE YOUR HAND.
WHERE IS IT?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IT'S ON THAT
PAGE.
SPEAKER:  CORRECT.  HE IS HIDING
ON THE TOP RIGHT.  HANDS DOWN.
LET'S TURN THE PAGE.  THIS
ENCHANTED FOREST IN ECUADOR IS A
FESTIVAL OF FLOWERS AND FRESH
WATER SPRINGS.  RAISE YOUR HAND
IF YOU SEE THOSE ZOOLOGISTS.
IT'S HARD TO SEE.  BECAUSE IN
THIS PICTURE IT IS CAMOUFLAGED.
THE SILOUETTE OF THE MAN, THE
ZOOLOGIST IS CAMOUFLAGED.
LET'S SEE WHERE IS
IT.  WHERE IS IT?
CAN YOU TELL?  DO YOU SEE IT?
WHO CAN HELP HER?  JUST STAND
UP.  JUST TELL ME.  WHERE IS IT?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE HE IS.  IT
IS BACK THERE IN THE BACKGROUND.
ACTUALLY ABOVE THE LETTER E.
THAT IS WHERE HE IS.  AND YOU
KNOW WHAT, IF YOU DON'T SEE IT
WELL LATER, I'M SURE THAT YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE A BOOK AND
OPEN IT AND FIND FOR YOURSELF.
HANDS.  ONLY HANDS.  NO WORDS.
OKAY SO HAVE I READ THIS PAGE?
NOT YET.  NOT YET.  I NEED TO
READ THE PAGE.  IT SAYS A
GAGGLE OF ROCKS GATHER TO
DISPLAY AND DANCE.  HUDDLES WITH
BURNS, NOTIONS, AND HAVE YOU
EVER SEEN BIRDS LIKE THAT?
AREN'T THOSE AMAZING BIRDS?  THE
RED AND BLACK BIRDS.  AREN'T
THEY AMAZING?  THEY ARE AMAZING.
SO RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU CAN
SEE THE ZOOLOGIST.  AND IF YOU
CAN SEE THE ZOOLOGIST, AND I
CALL ON YOU, YOU TELL ME WHERE
THE ZOOLOGIST IS.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IT'S OVER
THERE.  LIKE UNDER THAT.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
IT IS.  IT IS OVER THAT BIG HUGE
LEAF AND BEHIND IN THE
BACKGROUND.  SO TO THE RIGHT OF
THE RED AND BLACK PART OF THE
ROCK.  SO I HAVE TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING VERY SPECIAL ABOUT THE
END.  DO YOU SEE THE END?  AND
IN SPANISH IT'S ORMIGA.  BEGINS
WITH A LETTER
-- WHAT LETTER?
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].  SO SPANISH].  SO
ORMIGA IN SPANISH BEGINS WITH
THE LETTER H.  IT'S A LETTER IN
THE SPANISH ALPHABET THAT IS A
SILENT LETTER.  SOME OF YOU SAID
O.  SOME OF YOU SAID H RIGHT
AWAY.  THIS IS NOT ANY KIND OF
ORMIGA.  BUT NOT ANY KIND OF
ORMIGA.  NOT ANY KIND OF ARMY
ANT.  THIS ARMY ANT, THEY
ACTUALLY COME OUT IN SWAMPS OF
200,000 INDIVIDUALS.  THEY
BLANK THE FOREST, ALL BLACK,
THEY GO UP THE TREES AND GO UP
THE BRANCHES.  AND THEY EVEN GO
INSIDE THE HOMES OF THE LOCALS.
COULD YOU BELIEVE
IT?  MY GUIDE TOLD ME THAT AS
SOON AS YOU CAN HEAR THE ARMY
COMES, HAVE YOU
EVER HEARD AN ANT WALK?
IMAGINE HOW MANY ANTS ARE
WALKING IF
THEY  CAN HEAR THEM WALKING.  AS
SOON AS THE LOCALS HEAR THE
ANTS WALKING THEY LEAVE THEIR
HOUSES.
BECAUSE THEY COME INTO THE DOORS
AND WINDOWS AND WHATEVER THEY
WANT.  AND THE LOCALS KNOW NOT
TO MESS WITH THEIR ANTS.  THEY
LEAVE THEIR HOUSES AND COME BACK
WHEN IT'S SAFE TO BE IN THEIR
HOME WITHOUT ANTS.  THIS IS THE
ARMY ANTS.  IT'S NOT ANY KIND OF
ARMY ANTS.  QUESTIONS AT THE
END.  SO WE WERE
HERE.  LEAVES WITH INCREDIBLE
INSECTS AND A RESTING
IGUANA.  SPROUTS AND
GROW IN THIS JUNGLE.  SPROUT AND
GROW IN THIS GARDEN.  OH, I
FORGOT.  I FORGOT.  OKAY.  RAISE
YOUR HAND.  THIS IS VERY HARD
TO SEE AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST HERE.  IF YOU SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST DESCRIBE WHICH PART OF
THE ILLUSTRATION YOU CAN SEE
THE SCIENTIST, THE ZOOLOGIST.
LET'S SEE.  YOU IN THE CENTER?
DONDE
ESTA?
[SPEAKING SPANISH].  YES, IT'S
TO THE LEFT OF THE LETTER "I".
AND THE LETTER E.
IGUANA.  SO, DOWN BY THE REVERSE
SIDE, COLOR BLOOMS, A LIZARD
LIES AND INSIDE THE VINE, AND
THE LIGHT IS DRIZZLED.  THE
LIGHT IS DRIZZLED.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  I SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST.
SPEAKER:  FALLS ON SPRING, A
MONKEY, A BUTTERFLY AND A MOTH.
CLOUDS FOG AND MIST, NESTLE IN
THE CLOUD FOREST.  SOMEBODY WAS
UPSET BECAUSE I WENT BY AND I
DIDN'T SHOW THE ZOOLOGIST IN THE
OTHER ONE.  SO CAN YOU SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST
HERE?  RAISE YOUR HAND.
THE KAY.
SPEAKER:  THE SIDE OF THE KION.
THE SIDE OF THE FLOWER.  THE
LEFT-HAND SIDE OF THE KAY.  AND
RIGHT THERE BY THE RIVER.  CAN
YOU SEE IT?  OKAY.  LET'S SEE
THE NEXT ONE.  CAN YOU SPOT THE
ZOOLOGIST HERE?  THIS IS VERY
HARD TO SEE.  IT'S ALMOST THE
COLOR OF THE GROUND WHERE HE IS,
WHERE HE IS
WALKING ON.  IT IS VERY SMALL
AND HARD TO SEE.
LET'S SEE SOMEBODY IN THE BACK.
SOMEBODY IN THE BACK.  YES?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  THERE IN THE
MIDDLE.
SPEAKER:  IN THE MIDDLE.  CAN
YOU TELL ME THE COLOR OF THE
GROUND -- THE COLOR OF -- WHAT
COLOR IS THE GROUND HE IS
WALKING ON?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  A BUTTERFLY.
SPEAKER:  [SPEAKING SPANISH].
AH-HAH.  IT'S PURPLE.  THAT IS
EXACTLY WHERE HE IS.  RIGHT
THERE IN THE MIDDLE UNDERNEATH
THAT BEAUTIFUL BUTTERFLY.
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].  WE HAVE TWO.  THIS
IS INTERESTING.  THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I LOVE IN THE
SPANISH LANGUAGE.
BUTTERFLY IN
THE SPANISH LANGUAGE IS
MARIPOSA.  AND IN ENGLISH YOU
SAY THE NIGHTTIME BUTTERFLY.
AND IN SPANISH WE CALL IT
MARIPOSA
NOCHES.  SPANISH LANGUAGE.  AND
HIDDEN AMONGST ORGANS, THE
OLINGUITO SERVES A SUSPECTICAL
BEAR.  OH, LOOK AT MY OLINGUITO.
SO LET'S SEE.
WHAT LETTER OF THE ALPHABET IS
THIS?  CAN YOU RAISE YOUR HAND
IF YOU CAN TELL ME THE NAME OF
THE LETTER IN SPANISH?
[SPEAKING
SPANISH].  THIS IS THE LETTER
IN THE SPANISH ALPHABET THAT
DOES NOT EXIST IN THE ENGLISH
ALPHABET.  WHAT IS THE NAME OF
THIS
LETTER?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  N.
SPEAKER:  FOR THIS LETTER WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ROLES IN THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE.  SO I'M GOING
TO READ IT IN SPANISH.  SO YOU
LISTEN TO THE SOUND.  [SPEAKING
SPANISH].  PAINT A POT OF GOLD.
OKAY.  AND DID WE SEE THE
ZOOLOGIST?  NO, WE DID NOT.
LET'S SEE.  CAN ANYBODY FIND IT
OVER THERE, IN THE CORNER?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IN THERE NEXT
TO THE FLOWER.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S RIGHT.  NEXT TO
THE FLORA.  NEXT TO THE
NORBO.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE IT IS.  A
HUMMINGBIRD SIPS NECTOR.  AND
QUIETLY ALIKE, AND I SEE SO MANY
HANDS.  IT SEEMS YOU SPOTTED
THE ZOOLOGIST.  THIS ONE IS VERY
EASY TO SPOT.  LET'S SEE.  WHO
DO WE HAVE HERE?  OVER THERE.
YES?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IT IS BEHIND
THE HEAD.
SPEAKER:  IT IS BEHIND THE PALM.
THAT'S CORRECT.  DID YOU SEE?
THIS IS ANOTHER AMAZING SPECIES
HERE THAT CO-EXISTS WITH THE
OLINGUITO.  NOW, WHAT DID YOU
NOTICE ABOUT THE COLORS OF THE
SKY?  HAVE WE NOTICED SOMETHING?
HAVE WE NOTICED SOMETHING?
RAISE YOUR HAND.  HAVE WE
NOTICED SOMETHING ABOUT THE
COLOR OF THE SKY.  DO YOU THINK
THE SKY IS CHANGING?  DO YOU
THINK HE IS GETTING TO BE
EVENING?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  YES.
SPEAKER:  HM.  LET'S SEE WHAT IT
SAYS HERE.  LET'S
SEE WHAT IT SAYS.  GLASS FROGS
JUMP ON BRANCHES AND SETTLES ON
A TOAD AND A SALAMANDER.  DO YOU
SEE THE ZOOLOGIST?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  YEAH, HERE.
SPEAKER:  IT'S ON TOP.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  IT'S STANDING
ON THE MOUNTAIN NEXT TO THE
PLANT.
SPEAKER:  EXACTLY.  IT'S CAUGHT.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE NOTICED BUT
THAT ZOOLOGIST IS HOLDING A